feel alive today
do I need lipstick it really won't
change your personality hi guys welcome
to this video your regularly scheduled
friary
or your sporadically scheduled friary is
not in existence this week because I
didn't film much this week I just don't
want to film this week because I just
didn't want to film this week but I did
want to give myself permission to not
film which is really great for me pretty
sheet for you or not so if you're like
thanking God we don't need to see you
driving to the dentist anymore so
instead because I have a style guide
coming out Grayson style the art of
pretending you have it this is an actual
real copy of the actual book and that
was the worst pitch I could ever give it
you for this book because I am some
deities gift
to fashion I thought that I would do a
red carpet fashion review of the
People's Choice Awards which happened
this week the let's review some of the
red carpet fashion
shall we you don't have a choice but you
can click away shouldn't have told you
that's an option please stay carly rae
jepsen ok she's gonna be in greece so
i'm just assuming all of this is because
of greece or is it because of grace me
are you trying to hurt me
that's a cool dress maybe the photo was
strange you seem like a really great
person Tyler Oakley loves your album I
still have to listen to it I'm sure I
would love it too it's not that I don't
love it I just haven't listened to it
yet I have a lot of things to do like
staring it thanks Jay Johnson was there
because I had a saying you look great
and I'm talking to you like you're
listening clavicles are on the clock I
hope you gave them a holiday bonus cuz
they're working hard
Leah Michelle always looks good and
always looks like she's masking
Payne but the mask that you are covering
it with is super cute Claire Danes are
you hiding Mandy Patinkin under your
dress I hope so I choose him and I'm
people Natalie Dormer talk about game of
bones boners you look very sexy and are
those your real eyes or did you rent two
marbles and shove them in your face
those aren't real how did you do that
those aren't eyeball those are like two
screen savers in your eyes right now
watch John Stamos this is this is a
madame tussauds wax figure this is not
real
I got to look away Wow it's a Vanderpump
you look like Lisa Vanderpump are you
doing two loops at once if you curl half
the photo it's way different look than
the other half of the photo is this
photoshopped
are all the Real Housewives Holograms oh
my god Priyanka Chopra saddening I'm
just awful with all names you look great
where did you get all of those quarters
and all those gold wrapped chocolates
for that dress be careful the rain Shay
Mitchell how many wax figures did they
bring to the award show you look great
and your smile says you know it this is
like the evolution of the duck face duck
face with a secret what's the secret do
you only have one leg you can tell me
Shawn Mendes who live this Abercrombie &
Fitch model have such talent and charm
good job being cool and good please
always be good Alison Brie I'm a big fan
of Brie the cheese hurts my butt but
Alison ate my heart be my friend vanessa
hudgens
are you from the future meghan trainor
duckface with the secret you're doing it
Maddie Ziegler from Dance Moms are you
carrying a geode as a clutch you
couldn't let dance be your only talent
you have to be good at fashion too how
dare you call an ex are you
investigating a murder because this look
killed me
no it did it I mean it's fine you look
great I like blue you look like Jane
Lynch
she don't doesn't go out of style having
a great time and you are nailing it I
appreciate everything to be honest I
thought everyone at the People's Choice
Awards look great can't say anything bad
about it but what I can say is that I'm
going on tour for my food it's
officially announced I'm doing a bunch
of events across the United States for
the launch of the book in February if
you go to great style book calm you can
see all the cities that I'm coming to
and all of the bookstores that I will be
at in those specific cities and you can
get your tickets because I think some of
the places need tickets go on the
website it'll have all the information
for you guys I would really love
see you at any of the events that are
happening and I would really love to see
you without the book because I like it
so much and I want you to like it too so
what embrace style book calm one to
pre-order your copy of race and style
and two to check out where I'll be
across the United States and how you can
come lots of cool stuff happening I am
excited about it did that sounds
believable I hope so because I really
mean it
I don't know Portia de Rossi Portia is
honestly one of my fashion icons she
always looks so sleek she supports Ellen
like a mother sure love is a beautiful
accessory by